double arnaque pourquoi ribambelle la
première franchement pourquoi le mardi
c'est à dire comme nous c'est un
programme familial je regarde tout le
temps avec les enfants donc on ne le
regardera plus jamais je suis on se dire
ah ouais bon ok on va le regarder en
rites et le maroni mais on le regardera
donc pas vendre ni à autre chose
soumaré de notre de notre race
premièrement et 2e arnaque pardon on
nous a promis que ça allait revenir le
vendredi donc ça veut dire que tf1 nous
écoute pas on dit on martèle ont dit non
mais lorsque tu arrives en 10 pouces et
8 1
ça va venir alors il n'a pas son mot à
dire ah ba pourrait dire s'émeut le
moniteur ça fait partie du groupe minier
c'est alexia laroche joubert oui et on
adore alexia maleks ya c'est pas du tout
le même délire que là bas voilà c'est la
x est une bonne élève pour lui c'est le
mardi l'indicé de mardi voilà c'est ce
et voilà le sort elle était si on
m'avait dit c'est le mardi je redis nous
a
dit qu il s vous n'aurait pas dû faire
reposer la marque moi je pense qu'on
s'est étonné que oui
quand même et non pas ce qu'on fait
c'est pas un all star alain faustin all
star mais je pense que ça c'est c'est
peut-être un peu tôt mais je vous dire
c'est pas mieux le mardi le problème
c'est que tf1 souffre énormément oui on
le voit avec les avec les fictions donc
aujourd'hui le seul programme qui tient
la route le mardi ça reste quand même
koh lanta et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
on le voit tf1 et battu 5 fois sur 7 à
l'empreinte times donc forcément ils
sont obligés de sortir l'eau grosse
marque est aujourd'hui koh lanta le
mardi tient bien ils font moins que le
vendredi c'est sur les valeurs
mais ça fait 4 millions aujourd'hui il
sort il faut entre 2,2 et 2,5 donc
forcément c'est compliqué voilà merci
voyez 4 millions 3 voilà le mardi oui
ils l'ont fait aussi très vite il leur
lance parce qu'ils veulent effacer le
all star et l'image détestable donc du
coup ils ont avancé un peu et c'est vrai
que alexia laroche-joubert elle avait
dit qu'elle voulait le vendredi je
n'allais pas aller au bout ce père
qu'elle n'a pas fait un new case en
disant c'est vendredi au rien du coup
ils ont trouvé un compromis ils veulent
trouver de nouveaux héros moi je trouve
que c'est galvaudé lam akol un premier
essai c'est toujours le mardi non mais
ils ont elle a accepté la date du coup
elle a accepté d'avancer ils ont trouvé
là un moyen de le faire plus vite que
prévu ils l'ont tourné aux philippines
il devait diffuser plus tard et
finalement il le diffuse mardi
maintenant si vous avez compris ce qui
est dit
donner le même de démission mais entendu
ce qu'il a dit alors delphine wespiser
même si sur tf1 le vendredi fonctionne
bien et qu'ils ont un lancement d'un
nouveau programme n'importe quoi autant
le mettre le vendredi et le koh lanta
qui a déjà son public va peut-être
suivre le mardi mais au moins ça leur a
de la chance un pivot
missions courtes quoi
n'importe quel deal mais non je vous
adore la raison d'une
entente est pour quelque chose d'autre
et ce qui marche bien on peut le mettre
le mardi c'est une chose que j'aurais de
quoi moi
le totem maléfique et le totem
d'immunité qu'on connaît c'est la
nouveauté que j'ai quand même envie de
voir tout est magnifique et le taux
d'anomalie nantermod dit
au journal auto thème vous dire on
ad'autres tout est maudit alors oui marc
lavoine oui
écoutez moi je trouve ça alors si
peut-être peut-être j'ai vraiment un
truc intéressant à dire pour une fois
peut-être qu'ils ont déjà fait le mardi
qui pense que les gens ont pris
l'habitude et clapham allemand ah oui
exit pas pourquoi changer alors qu'on
l'a fait pendant ces débats vous est
quelque part non
ils vont relancer la star à domicile eux
conneries non déclaré flavie flament est
alors allé en plateau dépensé 2 watts
évidemment la fédé plateau il la
croisait d'ailleurs à l'olympia info il
exclut de bernard montiel oui elle
tournait à tourner donc finalement bien
que ça va devoir payer la pension on
s'est fait une idée les enfants sont
grands ah oui j'avais pas ya plus de
tension maintenant c'est bon ça va au
clé c'est que les quatre
noms mais aucune poursuite banner est
plein aux as écouté pendant bâton ça va
quand même à widnes où l'argent vous
l'avez remis dans la
rade je pense que ça peut fonctionner le
vendredi donc il faut il fonde la place
à la main voilà effectivement le mardi
c'était raté dommage de leur changer je
pense jimmy somerville
mais ce qui me ce qui est terrible pour
tf1 c'est quand même une mauvaise saison
que l'on tant en termes d'audience c'est
mieux que la moyenne de leur prime
quatre matches c'est un très bon prix
aujourd'hui huit élèves s'étaient fait
donc aujourd'hui le mardi c'est
tellement difficile pour eux qui
préfèrent mettre leurs blockbusters et
le vendredi vont tester des trucs comme
star à domicile donc c'est leur nouvelle
stratégie
le 2 juillet il ya le retour de the
voice donc là ça c'est très très fort
non non c'est vrai c'est pas fort du
tout c'est plus fort je voyais ces
ordres millions au box ils ont fini à
moins de 3 millions ouais mais ils ont
de nouvelles règles ça m'a pris mais de
nouvelles règles je
te dis que je voyais ça fera à décoller
c'est fini on n'en peut plus des gens
qui chantent je te dis la vérité à moi
des gens qui chantent un peu plus sans
rigoler ça y est les a vus je crois
qu'ils vont trouver des talents encore
une autre journée talence la chance à 2
tandis que moi je te dis que tu eu ce
vol et j'adore le jury j'aime beaucoup
j'aime bien les missions pendant mais je
pense que the voice oui mais je vole ça
dépasse plus jamais les 5 millions de
c'est fini il sait cessé de se terminer
je veux réussir plus d'urgence à
regarder the voice je pense à un vrai
bon un sens inverse sur koh lanta renée
sur koh lanta
ma chaussure qu'est ce
qui vous plaît un xanax
avec un verre d'eau n'ont pas de
relations gaz de sa rivale
je trouve dommage de ne pas écouter les
gens chez les gens ont refusé le
programme ont refusé le mardi je trouve
demain alors ils ont adhéré au programme
on peut s'il est un fiasco les mecs sont
partis bouffer au resto tous les soirs
sur je trouve dommage d'ailleurs plus du
fiasco de remettre le mardi 10
rencontres 500 foot votre avis et sortir
d'un fiasco s'arrêter bien de changer
une jours d'accord c'est moi j'annonce
une polémique c'est le tandem le totem
mode il fait quoi dont héritera le père
dans des épreuves porteurs de
malédiction ça ça va pas plaire ses
portes de discrimination et maintenant
tu as raison je suis d'accord le totem
au 10e pas mot sympa et puis mcinnis
laisse casse le bras le gars derrière
ça rêve c'est un peu la magie tu vois un
peu tout ouais j'ai beau dommage et noir
on sait pas ce que c'est papa il a
raison mais il voit les projets qui
arrivent et je me rappelle sur vidéo gag
et sané 1 quand un chien
[Applaudissements]